do you think that
there will be a day when an ai system
being the primary contributor let's say
plus wins the nobel prize in physics
obviously they'll give it to the humans
because we humans don't like to give
prizes to machines
it'll give it'll give it to the humans
behind the system you could argue that
ai's already been involved in some
nobel prizes probably maybe something
with black holes and stuff like that
yeah we don't like giving prizes to
other life forms
if someone wins a horse racing con
tested they don't give the price the
horse either it's true
uh but do you think that's we might be
able to see something like that
in our lifetimes when ai so like the
first
system i would say that makes us think
about a nobel prize
seriously is like alpha fold is making
us think about
uh in medicine physiology a nobel prize
perhaps discoveries that are a direct
result of something that's discovered by
alpha foal do you think in physics we
might be able to see that in our
lifetimes
i think what's probably going to happen
is more of a blurring
of the distinctions so
today if somebody uses a computer
to do a computation that gives them the
normal price nobody's going to dream of
giving the price of the computer they're
going to be like that was just a tool
i i think for these things also people
are just going to
for a long time view the computer as a
tool but what's going to
change is that as the ubiqui the
ubiquity of machine learning i think
at some point in my lifetime finding
a human physicist who knows nothing
about machine learning is going to be
about almost as hard as
it is today finding a human physicist
who doesn't says oh i don't know
anything about computers
right or i don't use math it would just
be a ridiculous concept
you see but the thing is there is a
magic moment though
like with alpha zero when the system
surprises us in a way where the best
people in the world
truly learn something from the system in
a way where you feel
like it's another entity like the way
people the way
magnus carlsen the way certain people
are looking at the work of alpha zero
it's like uh it it truly is no longer a
tool
in the in the sense that it doesn't feel
like a tool
it feels like some other entity so there
is a magic difference like where
where you're like uh you know if an ai
system is able to come up with an
insight that surprises everybody
in a some uh in some like
major way that's a phase shift in our
understanding of some particular science
or some particular aspect of physics i
feel like that
is no longer a tool and then you can
start to say
uh that like it perhaps deserves the
price
so for sure the more important the more
fundamental transformation
of the 21st century science is exactly
what you're saying which is
probably everybody will be doing machine
learning
it's to some degree like if you want to
be successful
at uh unlocking the mysteries of science
you should be doing machine learning but
it's just exciting to think about like
whether there will be one that comes
along that's super surprising
and they'll make us question
like who the real inventors are in this
world yeah
yeah i think the question of isn't if
it's gonna happen but when and and
but it's important in my mind the time
when that happens is also
more or less the same time when we get
artificial general intelligence yes
and then we have a lot bigger things to
worry about than whether they should get
the nobel prize or not right
yeah because when you have
machines that can outperform our best
scientists
at science they can probably outperform
us
at a lot of other stuff as well
which can at a minimum you know make
them incredibly powerful agents in
in the world you know and i think
it's a mistake to think we only have to
start worrying about
loss of control when machines get the
agi across the board where they can do
everything
all our jobs long before that
they'll be hugely influential we talked
at length about how the hacking of our
minds
with um
algorithms trying to get us glued to our
screens right has already
had a big impact on on society that was
an incredibly dumb algorithm in the
grand scheme of things right
just supervised machine learning yet
that had had huge impact
you